لا حربي روسي على اوكرانيا الان فقط قالت
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان وحدات من
الجيش الاوكراني صدرت هجمات للقوات
الروسيه في لوغانس كودونيس يوم امس طلع
المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الاوكرانيه قصفت مركزه للقوات
الروسيه في منطقه ديني برني على الضفه
اليسرى لنهر الدين بروما اسفر عن خسائر
كبيره في الاروع
من القوات الروسيه في ريف خرسون المحتل تم
نقل شاحنتين من القتل الى تابرسك ونقل 56
مصابا بجروح خطيره الى اقرب مستشفى توفي
منهم سته عشر ونفذ الطيران الاوكراني
وثلاثه عشر ضربه للعدو خلال اليوم الماضي
واصيب الثماني مناطق تجمع الافراد
والاسلحه وخمسه مواقع لانظمه الصواريخ
المضاده للطائره المعاديه
قالت سلطاته خير
جسيمه لحقت بمحطه كخوفك لانتاج الطاقه
الكهربائيه نتيجه القذف الاوكرانيه
القصفه ادى ايضا الى اضرار لاحقه بقناه
شمال القرم المائيه وقناتك خوفك المائيه
الواقعتين على نهر
او اكثر